good afternoon and welcome to at Yale
live I'm Eric gershon our guest today is
Yale astronomer Deborah Fisher who
studies and searches for planets far
outside Earth's own solar system she
will be discussing today how she goes
about her work will be taking some of
your questions and Deborah we're glad to
have you here ani cuius planet Earth
right my first question for you today is
could you define planet for us I don't
think everybody really understands what
a planet right well I think the simplest
definition is a planet is an object that
circles the Sun but it gets complicated
because there are also moons that circle
the planets and because we had Pluto in
our solar system and the International
Astronomical Union defined Pluto as not
being like the other planets in our
solar system but being more like the
Kuiper belt objects that are outside of
our solar system in other words one of
you know hundreds of other objects that
are similar to it so there's an
additional constraint that they added
and that is that the the object that the
planet has to be large enough that when
it's forming in a disk of dust and
debris that it clears a gap as it's
going through and we don't think that
Pluto did that now astronomers study all
aspects of universe stars galaxies black
holes how did how did planets become
your thing well i was actually finishing
graduate school just as the first
exoplanet was discovered and and my my
PhD thesis was on spectroscopy and
that's the technique that was being used
to find planets so you know really I
feel incredibly lucky it was partly
being in the right place at the right
time you know quite literally so you
know just luck and you used to term
exoplanet and if correct me if I'm wrong
but that's a planet that's almost any
planet outside of our own solar that's
right okay extras it's short for a
contraction of extrasolar planets
outside the solar system gotcha so how
are these planets that you study these
exoplanets how are they different from
the planets in our solar system well
that's a great question and it
one of the things that we were most
interested in because the first planets
that were discovered were very unlike
the planets in our solar system in the
sense that you know maybe they had
similar mass for example to Jupiter and
similar density but they were in orbits
that you know we're not 12 years long
but were four days hugging their stars
so that was a real surprise and that
really you know threw us for a loop we
had to think about the interpretation of
our data very hard with that one so I
think the one common thread the one
thing we've discovered is that planet
formation is a chaotic process there's
one thing that rules and its gravity so
you start out with a disk where the
planets are forming around the star and
there are thousands of wannabe planets
that are that are collecting debris and
matter and building up and then they
gravitationally interact with each other
and you know you end up with whatever
kind of a solar system i think is
gravitationally stable is possible and
that's what we're seeing have do many of
the exoplanets that you and others have
found resemble in any significant way
that the planets in our own solar system
well the characteristics that I like our
first of all we're finding many multiple
planet systems I think that's the rules
Paris homes uh well we find two three
four five six seven planets orbiting a
star a given star so that's a
characteristic that's similar to our own
solar system and we're finding a range
of masses that that go sort of from
Earth like in in their in their mass and
and maybe their composition or their
density all the way up to Jupiter like
so they they kind of span that range and
naturally it's it's hard to think about
other planets without wondering as one
of our viewers Kevin emailed us to ask
do you think it's likely that there's
life on other planets and and if there
is how will we recognize it right well
okay so that's why we're all in this
business okay we're not actually finding
planets is a great bonus we want to
understand you know how planets form and
how our solar system formed but I think
that you know and we all were sort of
quiet about this
beginning because there were there have
been a lot of kickback you know against
SETI the search for extraterrestrial
intelligence in the 1990s when the small
program federal funding was canceled so
we were all sort of quiet about the fact
that we're looking for planets because
we're looking for platforms for life and
so that's what drives us and do i think
that there's life elsewhere i don't see
how there cannot be actually do i think
it's like s technological there i think
the odds probably go down so it might be
very small numbers but it's not
inconceivable that somewhere else in our
Milky Way galaxy which is comprised of
something like 400 billion stars there's
another civilization asking similar
questions or has asked in the past or
we'll ask in the future similar
questions that we're asking are we alone
hmmm so to the extent that you can
separate your scientist self from your
person cells is what leads you to
believe that as a scientist that there
that there might be life out there right
oh so the first thing is that when we
found the first multi-planet system it
was around the star Epsilon Andromeda
there were three planets orbiting that
system and it was in 1999 I remember
walking across the campus looking at the
data and thinking wow this this really
suggests that planet formation is a
robust process something we didn't know
in 1994 all we knew stars could form
without any planets okay that was this
the facts we just didn't know and now
we're seeing this incredible bounty of
planets and multiple planet systems and
at exactly the same time I was listening
to the biologists who said Wow wherever
we find water on this planet it doesn't
matter if it's miles beneath the surface
of the earth you know or doesn't matter
how acidic it is if we find water we're
finding life and if you put those two
ideas together it's it's kind of hard to
imagine that life didn't spontaneously
you know arise somewhere else I think
one other on the quick comment is that
when we look at other stars and we
look through our own galaxy or other
galaxies we see that the galaxies are
glowing with molecules called polycyclic
aromatic hydrocarbons these are
components that can make up amino acids
so it's not even that life could arise
but it might be so exotic we wouldn't
recognize it I would bet a hundred
dollars that its carbon based life and
that you know eventually will will find
it'll be very different from what we are
but you know it there will be some
similarities there'll be some common
commonalities let's talk a little bit
about how astronomers go about finding
planets that they can't see that are so
far away that they can't be seen even
with the most powerful telescopes right
right so we have to look at the effect
of course now several techniques the
technique that I use is sometimes called
the wobble technique and we're watching
the star itself and we see we map out
the velocity of the star as it orbits a
common center of mass with the planet
now if you think about you know the mass
of the star is huge the mass of the
planet is tiny so the common center of
mass is are often inside the radius of
the star the star is executing you know
a very tiny orbit but we map that out
and we then infer the presence of a
planet that we can't see okay so that
technique that description might leave
you skeptical and that left most
astronomers skeptical until nineteen
ninety nine again when we said okay but
if we really ever right and our data
we're really seeing dynamical motion of
a planet being tugged or of a star being
tugged around by a planet then we will
eventually see a planet that passes
across the face of its star and when
that happens the Starlight will dim just
ever so slightly and we can tell you at
exactly what time that will happen
because we understand the orbit the
orbital parameters and so we made a
prediction for every planet that we
found if it's going to transit and that
was the we didn't know that if okay
because one one orbital parameter was
missing in our analysis but if it did
you know it would occur at exactly nine
thirty five pm
them and so we had our friends who are
measuring brightnesses of stars they
would look at our target star and they
look at four other stars and sure enough
one night you know in in late nineteen
ninety nine one of the stars dimmed just
at within 30 minutes of the predicted
time so it's a reproducible thing that
is very reproducible yeah we have a
question from the public David from
Carleton College emailing us to ask ask
you to elaborate a little bit and and
and and maybe suggest that well let me I
just asked the question could David's
question could could some irregularities
in celestial orbits be due to small
errors in the theory of general
relativity instead of due to supposed
planets right well rather than the
errors in the theory of general
relativity i would say that there are
certainly going to be general
relativistic effects that need to be
accounted for in very precise orbit
measurements and so we've done this for
example with mercury in our own solar
system but we're very close to mercury
and we get an incredibly precise you
know measurement of its position so we
can measure that general relativistic
perturbation of mercury and but it's at
such a tiny level that it's not yet
important for most of the other
planetary systems that we're looking at
but sure we're watching all the time
what else could be going on in the
system so so you've got two techniques
that you can kind of use one to verify
the others this is general idea exactly
so when did this hunt for exoplanets
really heat up when do you get going
yeah you know it's been going for
probably a century oh and most of the
attempts to find planets were failures
in the 1950s auto Struve predicted that
you know if you use the radial velocity
technique you should be able to get down
to a high enough precision so that you
could at least attack Jupiter's that are
close to their stars if they existed and
of course astronomers thought that's
ridiculous hot Jupiters are not going to
be close to their stars but the idea was
was right and people kept pushing and
pushing and you know things really
started to heat up as you put it in you
know the late 1980s when Dave late them
at Harvard
covered a brown dwarf orbiting its star
and then in 1995 when michelle maher and
DDA colo swiss astronomers discovered a
planet like Jupiter orbiting a star
that's very much like our Sun and then
as soon as that system was detected
there was like an aha moment where we
said oh you know we thought these
planets would be in 10 year orbits who
thought they'd be in four day orbits and
you start looking at the star
differently instead of taking one or two
observations per year you have to take
you know an observation every night to
detect those clothes and systems so we
changed our strategy we adapted once we
found the first planet and suddenly you
know they began to pour out so that now
there are hundreds with the Doppler
technique and thousands from the Kepler
mission and if i'm not mistaken there's
a planet there's a program here that
Yale participates in a call planet
hunters oh right which which actually
allows the public to participate in the
discovery of Planet so can you tell us a
little bit about that I'm so excited
about this project this is a project
that we started with some colleagues at
Oxford University the people at Oxford
had set up a whole series of citizen
science projects like Galaxy Zoo and and
one of the postdocs here Kevin shalinsky
kept asking me can we do something with
exoplanets the public loves exoplanets
and I think about it and saying yeah I
just can't think of really how we can
bring the public in until I saw the
Kepler data okay from the NASA Kepler
mission which is measuring the
brightness of 150,000 stars and looking
for tiny little transits as the stars go
in front of that as the planets go in
front of the stars so we we put together
a website planet hunters org which
serves up the Kepler light curves and
has the public look at the data and say
first of all does the star look reg you
know is a fairly constant and Sprite
nurse or is it lemonhope yeah just
briefly so are when you say you have the
public look at the data they looking at
numbers are they looking at visuals
they're looking at a graph okay and we
were really worried about showing people
a graph right that you know
and I tested on some high school
students and friends and we but we made
it I think visually appealing and anyway
the proof is that we now have over
170,000 users they have collectively put
in an amount of time assessing Kepler
light curves that is mind-boggling just
as background when I asked people on the
Kepler team they say oh I look at the
light curves all the time that's really
the way to go yes we have computer
algorithms but I spend so much time and
I say okay add up the amount of time
that you think you've spent over the
last three years and make it a run a
cumulative total so 24-7 you do nothing
but look at light curves what do you
think it adds up to and they'll you know
calculate I bet it's three months or I
bet it's four months well the hundred
and seventy thousand planet hunter users
have twenty-four seven okay put in a
cumulative of more than 300 years 300
man years looking at light curves and
these people are all over the world all
over the world all over the world have
their contributions led to the discovery
of new planets they absolutely have of
course they've detected most of the
planets that the Kepler algorithms are
finding Kepler has computer algorithms
that search through the data because the
amount of data is just overwhelming it's
heat it's just incredible but they've
also we published now for papers and the
first discoverers in the public for
those systems are co-authors on the
paper and these discoveries have helped
the Kepler team because the Kepler team
says wait why would we have missed that
right and they go back and they and they
tune up their algorithms or computer
algorithms so that their algorithms are
more efficient and again these are these
were primarily lay people perhaps lay
people with I mean surely with a strong
interest in astronomy but these are not
professionally trained astronomers for
the most part right and you know I would
say even a lot of people aren't sure
what they're looking at but they're
still finding things and what was
developed on the site that's the most
useful thing of all is a sort of a cadre
of super users who are actually
incredibly good amateur astronomers and
they're very generous with their time
and they're bringing the
newbies along and you know helping and
putting together collections and you
know I'm really making the site quite
powerful so how do professional
astronomers make use of the
contributions of the of the latest wrong
we can hardly keep up with them and so
we developed a second layer to the site
the you know the users we now have an
extraction algorithm which which decides
which votes are the votes of the public
are actually waited and the way that we
do this is we actually drop in fake
transits we know exactly what the depth
and the orbital period is and as people
recover those then we get an assessment
of you know how complete their analysis
is for four different ranges of planets
so in any case what we're doing is
extracting them the public's best
guesses for transits and we're moving
them to a site which we call second look
and we give our three thousand most
dedicated planet hunter users access to
second look so they then do a double
check sitting through all of that data
and then it comes out and we then the
professional astronomers are spending
time looking at the light curves going
to the Keck Observatory and collecting
more data to follow up and you know
analyzing the stars all sorts of things
and writing up the papers let me take
another question from from the public
Mike emails us to ask and this is
getting back to the topic about life the
potential for life on other planets
right if there is life on other planets
should we try to make contact with it
and that isn't really an astronomical
question no no it's a social asano yeah
exactly um I think unfortunately we
don't have much choice if there's life
imagine like there was another
civilization on a nearby star if it were
like us right and broadcasting TV
signals and radio signals we would have
discovered it already whether they
wanted us to or not those signals would
drift past us and so our signals have
been drifting out over time for the last
50 years 50 plus years now and so all
stars that are within 50 light-years and
that's
hundreds of stars of the of our son
could have the option of detecting our
signal so so we might not have a choice
and what we're really looking for I
think when we think about technological
life technological civilizations are
serendipitous discoveries eventually we
will want to harness the energy from the
Sun so we might build something called a
Dyson Sphere that essentially
encompasses the Sun as a sort of a grid
collects power and then channels it back
to our planet if you do that then it
could affect the spectrum of the Sun it
might change the color of the Sun in
some way for another observer so we're
looking all the time in our data for
something that just doesn't seem right
hmm yeah Pluto yeah planet or not planet
and what did you make of Pluto's
demotion as from the status of planet
within our own solar yeah I see it as
science in action this is the way
science goes we build a theory that
describe you know oh and also write our
whole convention for naming a planet
Pluto doesn't care if we call it a
planet or an outer solar system object
but we care because it helps to define
our understanding of what a planet is
and so I think from from lot from that
aspect I think it was pretty brave of
the International Astronomical Union to
go up against all those kindergartners
Pluto is not a planet there was a lot of
kickback but you know it was it was the
right thing to do Pluto doesn't look
like the other planets in our solar
system um let me ask you about sort of
how close the nearest exoplanets are
right are any of the planets outside of
our solar system places that humans
conceivably could travel to all right
good question okay so first of all the
first thing to make clear is that I said
before our galaxy right is this enormous
disk that has you know 400 billion stars
and then globular clusters sort of in a
spherical distribution around it but all
the planets that we are finding that the
Kepler mission is finding their all in a
tiny little bubble around the Sun okay
that's inside of the Milky Way galaxy so
we're not looking are detecting planets
in other gal right those are completely
virgin that's a virgin territory so
we're just talking about a little our
little tiny neighborhood and yet we're
finding all of these planets so sorry
what was your question so the question
was are there are there exoplanets that
human beings consider that we can travel
to ok so I think the closest to start
where we that we know has planets is
about 15 light-years away we're looking
very hard at the Alpha Centauri system
right now which you can see from the
southern hemisphere it's four
light-years away ok will we go there
that's actually hard for me to imagine
unless physics changes unless you know
it would just require an incredible
personal commitment to travel for 40 or
a hundred years right and have future
future generations be committing them to
space travel but what we will do is we
will start as technology advances I I
imagine that we will be sending little
BOTS you know and the perfect model is
your cell phone you said you accelerate
your cell phone to ten percent the speed
of light it gets the Alpha Centauri
system in 40 years it takes pictures
opens up right takes pictures and it
phones home since the signals back and
in the travel time for for that radio
signal is the speed of light so it's
only four years to get back so that kind
of thing I think will start happening
that is something to think about yeah
Debra thank you so much for joining us
today I can't believe the time has flown
by but it has and it's been great fun
and we'll have to talk to you again sure
thanks to all of you very much for
watching at Yale live with Deborah
Fisher professor of astronomy at Yale
University thanks very much join us
again at the end of the summer alright
thanks who's fun